I'm not interested in judging people's
hustle I'm interested in telling people
how I've accomplished what I've
accomplished which is I don't think I'm
that talented
I do think I've out worked people I
think that's real I also think it's
controllable and I think anybody who's
watching right now they might not be the
most talented entrepreneur or salesman
or a you know an amazing craft of
content but if they outwork somebody
that is a variable that feels in control
somebody wants to start a YouTube show
if they do it 365 days a year versus
somebody that does it 137 days a year
and they're equally as talented the
personnel that's a 365 is gonna win I
mean that's just truth and it's the only
practical advice that I think that can
give go get more talent I can't say that
but you know work harder and go to less
happy hours and don't watch you know if
hires fusions as house of cards yeah
that feels real and so you know to me I
think it's amazing to take the whole
month of August off in Europe I think
that's amazing work-life balance and for
many people that's the right advice it's
just not my little narrow view on the
world in the concept of if you complain
about what you want professional inch
well there's a way to fix it if your
content and you make fifty five thousand
euros a year and you have all of August
off and you're part of the dart team and
you spend tons of time with your kids
and your content and you do not complain
well then you're a hero to me
No below